Washington correspondent Paula Reid is a
lawyer who has been reporting on the
Miller probe since the beginning Paula
good morning this tweet by the president
yesterday crossed a line that he has
never crossed before so is it evidence
that he's trying to obstruct justice
we know sources have confirmed that the
Special Counsel is looking at the
president's tweets along with private
conversations to see if it all adds up
to obstruction of justice or any effort
to interfere in the Russia probe and
yesterday when the president took to
Twitter to issue this message that
specifically mentions his Attorney
General and an end to the Russia probe
you quickly saw his attorneys come out
and say look this is not a directive at
the Justice Department this is just the
president's opinion because they were
trying to undercut any suggestion that
this was obstruction of justice but
while he's certainly given the Special
Counsel one more piece of evidence he
also took something away he's taken away
attention for their first prosecution of
his former campaign chairman Paul
Manafort that trial was starting to grab
headlines and with this tweet storm the
president grabbed the news cycle right
back for some let me ask you this is our
the president's lawyers why are they
back in negotiations about sitting down
for this interview and what are the
parameters that they're discussing so
the outset is very unlikely that the
president will sit down with Special
Counsel
his lawyer Rudy Giuliani he has admitted
that he does not believe that that's in
the best interest of his client in this
situation but these negotiations
continue and these are mostly driven by
the president's attorneys they will send
off demands to the special counsel in
the special counsel response in this
instance the president's attorneys were
asking that there be no questions about
obstruction of justice not surprisingly
the special counsel rejected that but
did say they may be willing to limit the
number of questions so the negotiations
will continue but again based on my
sources and conversation to the
president's attorneys it is very
unlikely that this interview will ever
happen Paula thank you